le québec inc doit-il avoir peur du
projet de loi 96 vaste réforme de la
charte de la langue française notre ca
du vendredi avec le président de la
chambre de commerce du montréal
métropolitain michel leblanc quelle
douce défendre d'ailleurs de cette
accusation justement cette semaine en
commission parlementaire bonsoir bonsoir
et jean guy côté directeur général du
conseil québécois du commerce de détail
bonsoir bonsoir sur le fond mme celle
leblanc est ce que vous êtes ouvert à
l'idée de moderniser le loup de la doua
sort tout à fait tout à fait et on le
dit la loi 101 était rédigée et adoptée
à une époque où internet n'existait pas
on le voit youtube on voit les
plateformes évidemment il ya toute cette
mondialisation c'est une nouvelle
technologie ces nouvelles applications
c'est clair que la population aussi est
inquiète on voit des vars et des données
qui inquiète les gens donc c'est tout à
fait approprié et cette semaine je les
dis je pense le ministre plutôt
focalisés sur les points où on ne
s'entendait pas ou des points ou de
demander des précisions mais dans
l'ensemble le mieux des affaires
montréal a soutient que la langue
commune la langue de travail doit être
le français oui mais vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec le projet de loi tel qu'il
est composé présentement je vais y
revenir dans un instant mais je vais
entendre monsieur côté est-ce que vous
partager l'avis du gouvernement à
l'effet qu'on a laissé le français
décliner jusqu'à un point de rupture
dizaine ministre j'en ai marre de cette
semaine et qu'on doit renforcer les
mécanismes pour protéger la langue
française
mais c'est clair que nous on a
communiqué le fait qu' on était en
acajou les principes les objectifs du
projet toi qui avait été déposé pour
nous c'est clair que le français
démarrent au quart des activités
économiques doit demeurer au coeur des
activités économiques au québec pour les
détaillants pour les ensembles de
l'industrie donc que keyyo coup de barre
d'une modernisation pour nous cette ont
trouvé leur porte on avait quand même
des questions pour les sur certains
aspects des pneus ok on va y venir ça
aussi je reviens michel qu'est-ce qui
menacent tant chez le blanc et milieu
des affaires montréalais dans cette
réforme là il y a dans le projet de
l'eau ce concept que les entreprises
devront justifier un quand elle exige le
bilinguisme a connaissance de l'anglais
lors des embauches et ça soulève
énormément de questions il ministre a
réagi lorsque j'ai même évoqué la
possibilité que ce soit un fonctionnaire
qui décide c'est autorisé mais je posais
la question d'une façon assez large est
ce que c'est l'entreprise qui peut avec
son plan stratégique et ses besoins
déterminer ce qui est le besoin est ce
que c'est le candidat lui-même qui
devrait à pouvoir dire non non moi je
refuse que vous exigez la connaissance
de l'anglais est ce que c'est un
processus gouvernemental normé bref la
question des entreprises d'ici c'est
qu'elle exporte elles vont vers les
marchés internationaux c'est ce qu'on
espère qu'elles vont faire nos grands
champions industriels donc grandes
entreprises ont gagné des points à
l'étranger nos petites entreprises les
mots même factory des entreprises de
niche développe sur l'international
elles ont besoin de pouvoir embaucher et
ensuite tous les sièges sociaux les
sièges sociaux qu'on attire ici ben il
travaille avec tout le reste du canada
parfois avec le reste du monde il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'embauchés qui vont
nécessiter le bilinguisme en quoi ce
projet doit entraves sur ce que vous
décrivez là mais le projet de loi
précise que les entreprises devront de
façon
j'ai réaffirmé
vérifier si la connaissance de l'anglais
est nécessaire
et les employés les candidats pourraient
déposer des plaintes s'il juge que ça
devrait pas être exigé et c'est ce que
les entreprises on est à près du projet
de loi et je voudrais si les cabinets
d'avocats de montréal qui nous ont
alertés sur ces enjeux la même chose le
projet de loi précise que les contrats
qui seraient rédigées dans une autre
langue que le français pour être
considéré comme incompréhensible alors
c'est prisunic nos entreprises d'ici
surtout nos petites qui vont
contractualiser à partir d'ici avec des
entreprises internationales pourraient
systématiquement exigé que le contrôle
soit en anglais ce qu'on nous a alertés
c'est à ce moment que ces entreprises là
où on voit que contractualiser à partir
de toronto donc le risque s'est encore
une fois c'est fragiliser notre base
d'affaires vers l'international je
comprends jean guy côté dans le commerce
de détail est ce que les nouvelles
exigences al embauche
empêcher l'employeur de demander le
bilinguisme aux candidats sans la preuve
que c'est absolument nécessaire est ce
que dans votre secteur c'était
impensable
c'était pas ça dans un certain sens on
comprend que le projet de loi 14 3 tests
à remplir avant de pouvoir afficher un
poste dans une autre langue que le
français c'est pas juste l'anglais l'on
parle d'espagnol mandarin cantonais pour
comprendre que les acheteurs d'un
commerce de détail font affaire avec des
formes ça partout dans le monde donc ils
sont basés c'est mort hier mais doivent
appeler en chine de rappeler en
indonésie au rapt et un en europe pour
se procurer du matériel donc si
j'achetais le doivent à parler la langue
d'affaires des pays avec qui il faut en
faire et c'est un avantage comparatif
d'avoir sciemment donc le projet de loi
déposé rend la chose plus difficile que
celle des taux par la plus difficile
mais pas impossible quand même moi je
questionne l'âme la légitimité du
gouvernement du québec et du québec de
dire je dois protéger davantage dans
l'âme française je dois en protéger
davantage l'utilisation parce que on se
répète sur des décennies qu'on se dit à
nbc mais on vit dans un monde anglophone
dans un monde du travail anglophones
ainsi que ça fonctionne beaucoup en
anglais mais est ce que l'état ne sais
pas michel leblanc simplement de mieux
protéger sa langue et ça passe par par
certaines difficultés certainement pour
le secteur des affaires
alors oui mais faut savoir à quels
problèmes à ce qu'on désire s'attaquer
est ce que c'est la boutique de
montréal-nord où la boutique la rue
bernard où on exigerait le bilinguisme
alors qu'on dessert une population d'ici
est ce que c'est le commerce du vieux
montréal qui vident 40 60 % de touristes
qui ne parle pas nécessairement le
français vous ne vous savez quand on va
au japon on est très heureux de tomber
sur quelqu'un qui connaît l'anglais dans
le commerce où on va et finalement est
ce qu'on vise carrément les dynamiques
de sièges sociaux les dynamiques de
grandes entreprises ou de petites
entreprises et le la question de leur
compliquer la vie un peu ce qui met
souvent disent que c'est pas un
compromis acceptable moi je dit
j'aimerais ça qu on le précise et
j'aimerais ça que ce soit très clair
parce que les entreprises présentement
sont inquiètes et moi j'entends des
fleurons québécois me dire michel si on
ne fait pas attention nous allons d là
si certaines fonctions à l'exode qui est
du québec évidemment une reprise du
québec qui vous disent oui et ils ne le
diront pas publiquement ils sont très
sensibles à leur réputation oui et
l'inquiétude c'est que ça va se faire en
douceur c'est que ça va se faire parce
que si beaucoup plus rapide c'est plus
fonctionnel et lorsqu'on veut dire
éventuellement c'est mon dieu on a moins
de succès qu'avant or depuis une dizaine
d'années c'était exceptionnel le québec
montréal d'un point de vue économique
vont très bien alors l'idée c'est d'être
très très très nuancée sensible d'avoir
la bonne approche entendez tout de même
chose au conseil québécois du commerce
de détail jean guy côté
touché pour la question de déplacement
des deux d'entreprise ailleurs c'est pas
nécessairement on n était pas encore
enflammé ce qu'on entend beaucoup c'est
qu'on est dans un état de pénuries de
main d'oeuvre en commerce de détail
manquent plus de vingt mille personnes
des postes vacants donc c'est clair que
d'ajouter des limites supplémentaire
allant baudet complexification à
l'embauché en sorte que dans un état où
les détaillants se bat pour trouver des
gens pour qui ou dans lequel ils
pourraient trouver des talents de les
rechercher des employés c'est clair pour
l'instant que l'on aime être d'autres
barrières c'est un peu plus problème et
comment il percevait les changements que
québec veut apporter au règlement sur
l'affichage commercial est ce que est ce
qu'on pourrait revenir dans des
dans des moments où à l'époque là où il
ya des restaurants qui se faisait
reproché d'utiliser des mots comme pasta
ou fish'n'chips ces
gens qui côté de tu vois ce que je sais
ce que j'ai ce qu'on m'indique c'est que
vous savez de en 2016 et un nouveau
règlement on a juste et certains des
affiches des commerces a pris trois ans
pour le faire pour certains ça mettrait
au coude du jour donc ajouter des bois
français sur la devanture là le
gouvernement
revient avec une option où il faudrait
absolument qu'est plus de français que
la marque de commerce ou
dans une autre langue pour certains et
pour certains détails ans a décidé de
normes investissements dans de nouvelles
négociations que les autorités
municipales dans certains cas
donc c'est une inquiétude michel le
lanterneau je vais simplement dire c'est
une chose que d'avoir ikea cette chose
d'avoir les meubles ikea ça n'aurait
aucun sens d'avoir les meubles plus
groupe ikea et c'est là où je pense
qu'on va trop loin les marques de
commerce c'est une stratégie
d'entreprise son actif extrêmement
important donc c'est simplement là
pourquoi est ce qu'on s'en va vers la
dénaturer on dénature la stratégie de
l'entreprise avec les marques donc si je
vous comprends bien vous êtes pour des
changements la réforme de la loi 100
heureux mais vous n'êtes pas pour la
réforme est proposée par le projet de
loi 96
avec des ajustements je vous dirais
honnêtement ça veut dire que dans le
projet doit ya des bons constats qui
sont faits il ya des mesures qui doivent
juste être ajustée jean guy côté pour
terminer je vous dirais qu'il ya eu
énormément de mesures intéressant dans
le projet de loi français sur québec est
un exemple donc il y a des bonnes choses
on est en accord avec l'objectif on veut
juste peut-être certains ajustements à
la recette ok parfait on prend note de
sa merci messieurs d'avoir été là merci
et bonne soirée pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit